is a foot
the dream
it was clearer than a memory
and I heard the sound of a thundering
moms
splintering Shields and ringing swords
and I placed my hair put me I am from
and all the dragons roared as one
they consider the matter urgent that of
your succession who else would have a
claim the firstborn child
granera no Queen has ever sat the Iron
Throne the King has an heir Damon
Targaryen I will not be made to choose
between my brother and my daughter
[Music]
for nearest succession will be
challenged
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king your duty is to take a
new wife I have decided to name a new ad
I'm your head
you think that Ram will ever accept me
as their Queen a woman would not inherit
the Iron Throne because that is the
order of things when I'm Queen I will
create a new order
your family has dragons
yeah our power men should never have
trifled with
[Music]
Venera comes into Power she could cut
off any challenge to her succession
I am to inherit the iron throne
she will walk my way
Hearts remain as one oh our hearts were
never one
imagine just
on the iron throne
[Music]
where is sacrificed